Elle est belle la Lune. Elle
a inspiré des écrivains, des chanteurs
et aussi des cinéastes.
Des plus récents aussi.
Et en plus, elle inspire la peur.
Certains se demandent si elle ne va pas nous tomber sur la tête.
Dois-je mettre mon casque ?
C'est ce qu'on
va tirer au clair dans ma nouvelle vidéo.
On le sait tous,
la Terre exerce
une force d'attraction sur les objets.
C'est la fameuse gravité.
Oh oui, grave, mec !
Oui, il est grave.
Vous connaissez tous l'histoire
d'Isaac Newton et de sa pomme.
Elle tombe parce
qu'elle est attirée par la Terre.
Mais alors, pourquoi la Lune, qui est attirée par la Terre,
ne nous tombe pas dessus ?
Eh bien, parce qu'elle fonce.
La Lune se déplace à environ 1 km par
seconde, soit 3 600 km par heure.
Pour bien comprendre,
il faut remonter à ses origines.
Il y a 4,5 milliards d'années,
l'ancêtre de notre planète,
qu'on appelle une proto-Terre, est entré
en collision avec une autre protoplanète
que les scientifiques ont nommé Théia.
L'impact entre les deux aurait
éjecté à grande vitesse des tas de débris,
de roches, dont certains se sont ensuite
rassemblés pour former la Lune.
La Lune est donc le fruit d'une collision
avec la Terre.
Une fois rassemblés,
les débris ont gardé leur vitesse initiale
acquise au moment de l'éjection.
Et depuis, la Lune la conserve.
Jamy, t'as fumé la moquette ?
Il n'y a rien de fumeux là-dedans.
La Lune a conservé sa vitesse initiale
pour une raison simple.
Dans l'espace, il n'y a pas d'air.
Pas d'air, pas de frottement.
Il n'y a donc aucune raison
pour que la Lune ralentisse.
Et c'est parce qu'elle se déplace
à cette vitesse qu'elle ne tombe pas.
La vitesse et la gravité s'équilibrent.
Je vous montre.
D'un côté,  la Lune se déplace à la vitesse de
3 600 km par heure, mais de l'autre,
la Terre exerce une force d'attraction
et courbe la trajectoire,
ce qui l'empêche de s'éloigner.
S'il n'y avait pas la vitesse,
elle s'écraserait sur notre planète.
Et si elle allait plus vite, elle serait
plus forte que l'attraction terrestre
et elle s'éloignerait.
Seulement, en se déplaçant à 3 600 km par heure,
à la distance à laquelle elle se trouve,
vitesse et gravité s'équilibrent.
C'est comme si elle tombait
en permanence vers la Terre,
tout en restant toujours aussi éloignée
d'elle.
Au passage, c'est le même principe
qui empêche la Terre
de s'écraser sur le Soleil.
Ouf !
Et c'est aussi celui qui est utilisé
pour maintenir les satellites artificiels,
l'ISS, par exemple,
en orbite autour de la Terre.
Alors, serait-il possible
qu'un jour cet équilibre se rompe ?
Eh bien non, c'est presque impossible.
Un scientifique américain, Rhett Allain,
professeur de physique, s'est même amusé
à faire des simulations
pour savoir quelle force il faudrait
appliquer sur la Lune, pendant
combien de temps et dans quelle direction,
pour lui faire quitter son orbite.
Il en conclut que même en poussant
pendant une heure avec une force 50 fois
supérieure à la gravité terrestre... La Lune ne nous tomberait pas dessus !
Ouf !
Il faudrait en fait une force encore plus grande ou pendant plus longtemps,
et ça commence à faire beaucoup.
En fait,
c'est plutôt l'inverse qui se passe.
La Lune s'éloigne.
Que voulez-vous, messieurs dames ?
Tout fout le camp.
Enfin, bon, n'exagérons rien.
Tout cela est encore dû aux forces d'attraction qui créent des marées.
On l'a dit, la Terre attire la Lune,
mais la Lune exerce aussi
son attraction sur la Terre.
Cette attraction est responsable
des marées,
marées océaniques,
mais aussi marées terrestres.
J'ai déjà fait une vidéo à ce sujet.
Je vous la glisse dans le petit i, juste là.
Même sur la terre ferme, nous montons et descendons
sans nous en rendre compte, d'une vingtaine de centimètres,
deux fois par jour.
Or, ces déformations de notre planète
provoquent des frottements,
de la chaleur se dissipe.
Bref, il y a une perte d'énergie.
Conséquence de cette perte d'énergie,
la vitesse de rotation de la Terre
diminue
d'environ 2 millièmes de seconde tous les 100 ans.
Ce qui prolonge d'autant la durée d'un jour terrestre.
A ce rythme-là,
les jours seront plus longs d'une minute
dans 3 millions d'années.
Mais si la Lune provoque
des marées sur Terre,
la Terre en provoque aussi sur la Lune,
qui ont cette fois une autre conséquence.
La Lune s'éloigne de nous,
d'environ 3,8 cm par an.
Bon, c'est vrai,
sur une distance de 384400 km en moyenne,
ça ne se voit pas beaucoup.
Mais son éloignement aura tout de même
une conséquence observable.
Dans quelques millions d'années,
comme la Lune sera plus éloignée de nous,
elle n'aura plus la même taille apparente
que le Soleil et ne pourra donc plus
le masquer totalement et nous offrir le
magnifique spectacle d'une éclipse totale.
En revanche, cet éloignement ne va pas freiner les projets de voyage lunaire.
Les Américains comptent bien y envoyer
de nouveaux humains au plus tôt d'ici 2025.
56 ans après leur première visite,
une sorte de seconde lune de miel.
Et ils ne sont pas les seuls.
Les Chinois projettent
d'en fouler le sol en 2030.
Et puis, si vous n'êtes pas du voyage,
rien ne vous empêche de continuer
à être dans la Lune.
Pas vrai, frangin ?
Quant à vous, ne soyez pas dans la Lune,
abonnez-vous !
Allez, à bientôt
les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux.